puts the puck in behind the net that's tipped Away
by valard and the loose pucks gathered in and fed
ahead by Dello out the center ice taken back by
the Flames Walker de chipped in RKA honored in
front was a chance turned away just power play
was 23rd last season Flames had the fourth best
penalty kill it was very good a year ago morisy
walks the line again that unit stays out there
Connor all the way across marks from nice save
as he's able to fight off that opportunity by gab
gardi hter one more time side of the goal gardy
to the other side disciple and fr ey follow turn
side Mar rebound off to the corner Jaric on the
P Anderson at the point Jonathan hubo top of the
circle takes a look makes a move and deep with
the pass turn what a save up padoo looking for
his first NHL goal Conor hot got that left leg
out and a Punch play all the way down the ice but
very eventful first period here's Matt Coronado
looking for his first goal of the season on to
the line to Hanahan Hanahan across Dylan du back
to Noah Hanahan Hanahan takes a look here's RKA
shoots never got it there rebound the score on the
power play ma jaani makes it one up the [Applause]
calary power play their theme is to get lots
of Pucks in that with traffic and you see
Michael backman going to the front rid going
to get the Pucket just throw it in front it
goes off the skate of Keon right onto the
Stick of M japani nothing that huk can do
bad break for the Jets when you consider how
well they've started but the Flames are on
the board first Neil Pon career year for him
last year 10 goals and third 33 points gets
the puck to Samberg and here comes Connor over
the line with a shot scores K Conor sneaks one
through Jacob arrom and we talked about Conor
he's got that shot that's able to find its way
past the Flames goalie and tie this game at
one they exit their Zone nicely here's that
nice pass right through the middle and watch how
Conor just changes the angle and the puck goes
through the legs of the defenseman leag and
I know marks is still not going to be happy
with it but there is a reason why this shot
from well out watch that beautiful play by
Conor Walker derer back to sidorov here's weager
rer scor wager off the draw puts it
home and the Flames up 2 [Applause]
one tremendous and you see that's just
fighting for pucks that's on the that's
Walker doer getting the puck back to
the point lots of traffic with Greer
in front that's how you just sort of sip pucks
through and would seem like a fairly innocent
shot Jets chip the puck in look to answer back
here's a chance and a glove save marks from off
Kari who came racing in off that left wing for
this period we go back upstairs gentlemen all
right thank you Ryan Rick ball Kelly Rudy in
the broadcast booth and two perfect picks yes
both guys as Ryan mentioned have been with their
teams for a long time 10th season now for Lowry
and Winnipeg Conor down the wing in front TI just
wide of the goal by gab valard C comes around far
side back down low valard in front cut stopped
by marstrom big stop marks him off Kyle Conor
from Point Blank Range cry bouncing pass makes a
play to huberto back to the point to Anderson no
work it across takes a look hubero passing here's
corado with a shot and hel there to make the save
off the pad stays in play off the Ard glass being
hassled by tanet Jets keep the pressure on Dello
looking for a deflection in front iollo couldn't
get a stick to it half to the puck finds Lowry
glovs it down deelo long shot scores I follow
in front with a tip gets his first as a jet and
this one's all tied up a two [Applause] where
Adam Lowry grabs it and then quickly assesses
what's happening right here he's going to think I
got to just get it to the point and there's aalo
with a beautiful redirect Deo with a real nice
setup just throwing it right into the feet to
the legs of ialo and that is a terrific deflection
shley i fs in front there's a pass pass though to
valard the trailer and he's able to get that on
goal turned away by Mar still a minute five left
in this winipeg power play that top unit stays out
there I of follow to Connor Connor to shley with a
shot fought off by marstrom puck bed around lanes
are on and here goes Len the backman shorthanded
Len takes a look try to hit Hanan who would join
the rush now plays it back Anderson [Applause]
SC [Applause] huge stop at the other end and
then a shorthanded goal by Rasmus Anderson
and it's two1 calary Anderson he's going
to get up in the pl watch his from looks
a little bit dangerous but he saucers it
in there over the Stick of Conor right
there right to Rasmus Anderson his second
short-handed goal of his career incredible
action Peretti takes the pass into eers down
the wing eers High slop P with a shot block
SMI rebound stop sto again so the Jets
will open up period three on the man
Advantage Flames control off the draw though TANF
puts one down the ice on goal
where heluk leaves it for Josh
morrisy arrom over to Hanan to the
point KN out Morris he kept it in
here's shley scores Mark shley with
542 to go in the third ties it up at
three and it seemed like it was just going to
be a matter of time that they're going to get
rewarded how about Conor with the for check
and creating that turnover getting it back
to the point and then shley watches nice
release he's looking at that spot all the
way it doesn't look as though Marksman leaves
much room whatsoever Marksman knows it Conor
to his right lindol facing off against Kari
Flames control off the draw weager shoots
and that's off traffic wide Jonathan huo
puts the puck behind the that's to maon L
[Applause] he's they catch the Jets tired after
the icing call and Elias Lindo from maon puts
Calgary back on top but the great thing here
watch how huberto is going to get this deep you
know you're tired so you can get the other
team running around making mistakes gets a
download of mapani and without ever waiting
he recognizes that he has lyol going to the
front of the neck and the Jets are too tired to
react I believe those Sor that that was his man
Puck battle top of the circle L able to bustle
that to the corner he'll Fe it ahead and they
go pass morl racing after it's hubo and they up
to out here's hubo off the post maon follows up
[Applause]
scores second of the night for adran japani
and that'll seal it with 6.1 to go flames
on top five three watch this play right there
just gets a pass Mory now and hoor surprisingly
kuero hits the post with M comes in took a
while to get up and he was hunched over as
he went off as the final seconds wind down
well Jets had 38 shots of Jacob marstrom he
stopped 35 of them and was the single biggest
factor in the Flames winning the season opener